the first anniversary of the deadly
january 6th assault on the capitol
former president trump has cancelled a
rally scheduled to mark the occasion in
his way tomorrow
and the house select committee
investigating the attack meanwhile is
seeking cooperation from fox news host
sean hannity about his communication
with the white house before the riot the
committee has also expressed interest in
speaking directly with former vice
president mike pence
meanwhile tomorrow's anniversary may be
a struggle for some of the police
officers who were beaten and abused by
rioters on that day
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge sat down with a
veteran capitol police officer who is
demanding accountability catherine good
morning tony sergeant angelina gunnell
told cbs news that january 6 was the day
he thought he would die
at the west entrance as rioter scaled
scaffolding set up for the inauguration
capitol police sergeant akolina gonnell
was beaten and his spirit nearly broken
are you suffering yes i mean
from
every
day for me it's been a january 6. on
twitter the 16-year veteran of the
capitol police force documented his
injuries to dispel claims that minimize
last year's violence canal told us he
still can't shake the trauma the way i
sleep
from that way
by
the way i put my shirt on the way i take
a shower
the physical therapy twice a week
the mental health therapy
once a week gannel who testified to
congress earlier this year is now doing
administrative work rather than patrols
it's been hard emotionally physically
and financially as well too the select
committee investigating the attack on
the capitol now wants to hear from fox
news host sean hannity about his text
messages with the white house before the
riots on december 31st hannity texted
then white house chief of staff mark
meadows i do not see january 6 happening
the way he is being told five days later
to an unknown recipient hannity wrote
i'm very worried about the next 48 hours
and on january 10th to meadows and ohio
congressman jim jordan guys we have a
clear path to land the plane in nine
days he can't mention the election again
hannity's lawyer told cbs news they are
reviewing the committee's request
now nearly a year after about 140 police
officers were assaulted some with lethal
weapons gunnell says action needs to be
taken to prevent this from happening
again if
we don't put a deterrent on some of
these
and hold people accountable for what
they did
this could be a recurring
thing every four years
three more officers who defended the
capitol on january 6 are suing former
president trump for his alleged wrongful
conduct inciting a riot this lawsuit
should be heard by a federal judge next
week tony
concept of that happening every four
years is chilling catherine thank you
very much for that interview